what is your response to those who say  nominating a socialist would reelect  Donald Trump well I think the responses  that the polls last poll I saw had as 10  points ahead of Donald Trump because the  American people understand that Trump is  a phony their Trump is a pathological  liar and a racist and that he lied to  the American people during his campaign  he said he was going to stand up for  working families while President Trump  you're not standing up for working  families  when you try to throw 32 million people  off their health care that they have and  that 83 percent of your tax benefits go  to the top one percent that's how we be  Trump we expose them for the fraud that  he is  [Applause]